this one it was get amazing I read I and
what I loved about it is is that I was
at a pizza place right by the comedy
store that was eating and across the
street
this is Diplo and it's just James on the
poster so that's cool
do you don't at me hey no that's cool I
like it I did not design the poster so
in Diplo's real life when he's
performing in Vegas yeah when he has a
billboard of him is his manager she's
got you dead to rights but first of all
what you guys are misinterpreting what I
just say I resent the accusation what I
said you can rewind the tape is that I
was eating pizza at Little Joe's okay
and I was eating it and I look up and I
see a billboard with James with a coffee
mug right with the little grey beanie
and this is what would Diplo do and this
is vice land and whatnot right and I
felt joy in my heart he was the only one
on the poster adding that little and
a button which is a good thing that he
was the only one you know Dylan Francis
is a name too he's great isn't he yeah
I'd he won't text me back but he's so
good he's a busy dude he'd [ __ ] it I get
all they are all busy Dylan Dylan I
didn't know what to expect its Dylan's a
DJ he's as big as Diplo in a lot of
circles oh yeah and he when we shot so
we did like a like a proof-of-concept
thing after the commercial that we
showed to Spike Jonze which is a little
more totally in line with what we wanted
to do it's like a so we just we went to
the Mad Decent block party and started
improving we threw me on stage dressed
as Wes the dressed as Diplo yeah and
then but Dylan jumped in and started
improving with us and Dermer was like
you know we should think of having Dylan
I'm like yeah he's great I'm nice too
but is he like that how work is he
really great and
and dimmer it goes like we'll check out
a snapchat and I did are they okay this
guy is super clever he's so creative
yeah and so I wrote this role for him is
like this hanger on yeah super low IQ
cuz that cuz one thing I know about
Dylan's he he's likable he's charming
yeah and I thought he could be charming
like all the way down to like an IQ so
low he's barely functioning and I didn't
really know what to expect and he
crushed it belly crush yet he is also
really just he he has comedy energy yeah
like being around a comic like yeah he
really does I'm like I didn't I didn't
even know who he was I thought he was
from The Groundlings - that's how yeah
honestly I know I went oh they got
Michael and they probably got this guy
from The Groundlings yeah I didn't know
he was a DJ until later I mean I'm being
completely [ __ ] real with you when
we're at the table read and he jumped in
in a bit with H Michael kroner yeah held
his own yeah I was like woah yeah yeah
damn does um Brandon Derman do crystal
meth no why does he look like he does
like a guy who should who should be
selling you van I'm not kidding you if
you saw him walking down the street you
would like kind of you wouldn't check
your wallet do you think it's got the
kindest eyes he doesn't have your eyes
the crow he's he doesn't has to doubling
he's a baby thank you baby
when do you know was here you said he
looked like he worked at a circle K this
is why he's pure this is no no this is
my brother
I know see that's what I'm saying you
need whites like this this is this guy
right here is Schindler if he was in
Germany he would smuggle like 30 of them
out in his pocket right he's one of
those he's not he was he's not what
Trump you know I mean supports you know
I should get a bunch of guys like me we
should walk down the street Jenny
White's like us
[ __ ] good whites good whites like you
know let's go get these two in that
wouldn't ya I wouldn't get
misinterpreted no you Bobby Ledo
[Music]